you can't use a crane kick to solve all
of life's problems but you can come
close the ending of cobra kai season 5
proves it
after five seasons it seems that cobra
kai's dojo war may finally be over terry
silver monopolized karate classes in the
valley just in time to get sent to
prison and his students departed in mass
exodus after discovering that he was
both a cheater and a felon while it's
unclear exactly what will become of his
many dojos it seems that he won't be
around to continue teaching his abusive
style to kids anytime soon additionally
johnny and daniel's rivalry is mostly
quenched by the time season 5 starts and
they become true friends by the finale
so the dojo war must be over right well
that still remains to be seen by the end
of season 5 there are basically no kids
left to carry on the tradition of evil
karate tory kenny and devin the last
three main characters enrolled in the
dojo all repent for their harmful ways
and make amends with the good guys by
the time episode 10 concludes it seems
certain that silver will serve hard time
for his crimes and while john crease
does escape from prison by the end of
season 5 he's in no position to start
teaching again still some things remain
murky will crease somehow reclaim the
dojos will johnny will new evil sensei
kim daeun take the reigns the war may be
over but there's still the aftermath to
deal with
for most of the finale it's implied that
john crease might be dead after a brutal
stabbing in prison and given the
widespread harm creases rot throughout
his life an unceremonious end of that
nature almost seems fitting
sweep
[Applause]
however the final scene of season five
shows that crease is still very much
alive after besting a number of his
fellow inmates in a brawl crease earns
their loyalty this allows him to stage a
fake stabbing with two of the other
prisoners start arguing crease makes a
show of getting in between them to stop
the fight but his only reward is what
appears to be a fatal attack after being
taken into a less secure medical area
it's revealed that the blood on his
shirt isn't blood but red jello a call
back to earlier in the season the only
way this plan would have worked is if
both arguing prisoners were in on it
from the start which seems to be the
implication priest then dispatches the
surrounding guards and escapes using a
key card stolen from the prison
psychologist with terry silver likely
heading to jail himself crease looks
primed to return as the big bad of the
show going forward however he also seems
to genuinely want a shot at redemption
it remains to be seen if he'll get one
the shadow of pat morita's mr miyagi has
always loomed large over cobra kai his
absence is particularly felt in season 5
because of terry silver's expanded role
as the show's ultimate villain any fan
of the karate kid would probably put
good money on a prime mr miyagi having
the edge on any of the koberkai
characters isn't a fair fight but he's
sadly not around to stand up against
silver or is he over the course of
season 5 silver defeats both daniel
larusso and chosen to gucci in one on
one duels though jose is still decently
inebriated when he faces silver and
daniel is completely ambushed but in the
season finale daniel is victorious in
his rematch thanks to chosen having
softened him up beforehand
in the end it takes both daniel and
chozin to take silver down which is kind
of poetic as the two most direct
descendants of mr miyagi's karate style
they combine to form some approximation
of what the old master was capable of in
this way it's almost like mr miyagi
himself defeats silver and cobra kai
which makes it especially significant
that daniel finishes the villain off
with a crane kick
from the start cobra kai has been a show
about rivals and rivalries johnny
reopens a cobra kai dojo because he's
still not overlooking to daniel and the
karate kid daniel in turn starts
training new miyagi doe students because
of the same rivalry as the show
progresses numerous other storylines
emerged in the same vein from miguel and
robbie's mutual hatred to the beat
between sam and tori by the end of cobra
kai's season 5 pretty much all of those
rivalries have melted away daniel and
johnny are friends miguel and ravi make
amends tori and sam join forces and even
the dojo war itself seems to end with
the arrest of terry silver even the
smaller rivalries like the one between
robbie and kenny payne are quashed by
the end of the season with kris escaping
from prison there's still a potentially
villainous force on the loose but cobra
kai might be better off exploring a
different kind of rivalry going forward
the main story line still left hanging
at the end of season 5 is the
international karate tournament known as
the sekai taikai to which all three main
cobra kai dojos are invited for a while
it looked like the show's main rivalries
would play out there but now that
everyone's friends again the tournament
could be even more interesting a
friendly rivalry can be just as
compelling as a hateful one and the
characters now have a chance to learn
from each other and become even stronger
there are still some plot threads left
dangling in the wind after the events of
cobra kai season 5. but the season
finale still manages to feel like a full
circle moment for the entire karate kid
saga the only thing missing is an
appearance from hillary swank's julia
pierce star of the next karate kid but
when it comes to the original trilogy
starring mr miyagi and daniel larusso
cobra kai's season 5 ties up pretty much
every loose end the events of the first
film are finally and fully laid to rest
with a brotherly bond established
between daniel and johnny miyagi dough
continues on to the next generation and
cobra kai is defeated the karate kid
part 2 also receives a second pass with
season 5's extensive arc for chosen and
of course daniel finally puts terry
silver in his place facing the trauma he
caused him in his youth and defeating
him with mr miyagi's signature move the
crane kick even the earlier plot lines
of cobra kai feel mostly wrapped up by
the end of season 5. the original
generation of teens robbie miguel sam
and tori now have their own acolytes and
kenny and devin among others in this way
season 5 feels like the end of a cycle
and while there's still an international
tournament to attend the story feels
like it's properly entering a new
chapter even mike barnes gets a bit of
redemption daniel if there is one guy in
this world that does know me an apology
believe me it's you
one of the smaller story lines at the
end of cobra kai's season 5 involves
chozen's secret love for kumeko the
woman he grew up with in okinawa chozen
confesses his feelings to johnny during
their booze-soaked night out in episode
9 and johnny leaks the details to daniel
after receiving encouragement from them
both chozin calls comeco and confesses
some level of his feelings but with all
the excitement that occurs directly
after him this plot line is left hanging
after the finale it would be cute to see
chozen and komeko get a happy ending
together especially given all they went
through in the karate kid part 2. chozan
was undoubtedly a terrible person in his
youth and that's partially due to the
harmful influences he had in his life
either way he's clearly repentant and
makes a meaningful redemption journey in
cobra kai season 5. after surviving an
almost fatal duel with silver chozen
definitely deserves some time to rest
and it seems likely that komeco would be
interested in joining him many of the
other big cobra kai romance storylines
come back to a point to balance by the
end of season 5. daniel on amanda's
marriage is stronger than ever johnny
makes real strides to be a better man
for carmen sam and miguel get back
together and so did tori and robbie
after so much drama it's nice to see
everyone happy
terry silver gets a big promotion from
cove co-villain to big bad in cobra kai
season 5 and he presents a very
different kind of evil than that of john
crease measured and calculated in almost
every area of his life silver is
obsessed with dominance on a big picture
level his plans are global fitting for a
man of his considerable financial
resources but in the season 5 finale we
also see the manic persona silverwares
in the karate kid part 3.
thomas ian griffith truly stands out in
season 5 and he has a particularly great
performance in the final episode you can
see something shift behind silver's eyes
when johnny chosen and mike barnes break
into his house a flicker of the rage and
ego hidden beneath his veneer of
civility at his core silver wants an
excuse to fight it's the reason he
leaves his quiet rich life in cobra kai
season 4 to team up with crease again
all the wealth he's acquired through
nefarious means is hollow without the
ability to demonstrate his actual
strength so he challenges chosen to a
sword fight and even after nearly losing
silver seems okay with death i was meant
to die and about
do it
to win the fight he uses a dirty tactic
to defeat chosen it's this duplicity in
silver the claims of honor with the acts
of cowardice that ultimately leads to
his downfall perhaps the most shocking
thing about cobra kai's season 5 is that
good truly wins nearly every piece of
the story ends in a triumphant way
silver loses as students abandon the
dojo everyone makes amends and nobody
dies it's almost like a fairy tale
albeit one with a lot more karate in the
world of cobra kai though this isn't out
of place throughout the show evil is
only ever won when employing dirty
strategies sam loses cobra kai season
4's all valley tournament because of a
corrupt referee for instance silver
defeats chozen with a slice from his
sword while daniel's friend is
distracted in this world where balance
is an absolute aspirational value the
only thing holding most characters back
is their own issues but in season 5
those issues mostly get resolved robbie
reconnects with his father who gets his
own life fully together in turn sam and
tori admit their past mistakes and move
forward as does chosen and in the final
moments of the season the cobra kai dojo
is defeated by the revelation that
silver is actually a duplicitous snake
yes the good guys win in cobra kai
season 5 but they win by redeeming the
villains not by dominating them silver
is the only character not offered some
kind of redemption in the season and
it's no coincidence that he is also the
only one left in chains
for all the closure provided by the end
of cobra kai season 5 there are still
some things left unresolved the biggest
hanging storyline involves the sekai
taikai the massive international karate
tournament that miyagido and eagle fang
will compete in that sure sounds like
the kind of event that would be a
perfect send-off for the show but that
remains to be seen there are still some
lingering questions that could be
answered in a final tournament arc julie
pierce the only major character from the
karate kid movies yet to appear in the
series could finally show up and share
stories about mr miyagi with daniel
miguel's father could return as the
backer of one of the tournament's other
entrants given his connections to
professional fighting and of course kris
could show up to screw everyone over or
possibly to actually redeem himself once
and for all what makes the international
tournament plot so interesting is the
newly mended relationships between the
main characters it would be fun to watch
tori and sam actually bond over a
sparring match or see miguel and robbie
team up in some kind of two-on-two
cobra kai's season 5 is at its best when
it lets the characters really get to
know each other and push each other to
change for the better good luck we
haven't seen the last of that
[Music]